les élections au pérou monde en parle ce
matin avec meriem l'arrivée notre
journaliste de la rédaction web d'arte
et france bonjour meriem ravi de vous
retrouver dans la matinale rt france
alors on a vu que la situation politique
est un peu compliquée en ce moment au
pérou les esprits s'échauffent dans les
rues du pays et l'onu appelle au calme
pourquoi la tente est elle si longue
bonjean magali en effet oui l'élection a
eu lieu le 6 juin et nous sommes le 17
et aucun vainqueur n'a été proclamé
officiellement pourtant 100% des
bulletins sont désormais comptés et
donne l'instituteur syndicaliste le
candidat de gauche pedro castillo en
tête avec 50,12 % des voix ça confirme
une tendance qui se dessinait depuis le
lendemain de l'élection
quand les voix des campagnes et des
zones les plus pauvres majoritairement
favorables à castillon ont commencé à
arriver alors pour répondre à votre
question à la teinte est très longue car
les autorités électorales sont mises
sous pression maximale par la candidate
de droite keiko fujimori dont les
partisans demandent désormais ni plus ni
moins que l'annulation de l'élection
alors sur quoi ça va signer pour
demander cette annulation meriem c'est
une bonne question premièrement il y a
seulement 45 mille voix qui séparent les
deux candidats les partisans de fujimori
sont donc frustrés et crie à la fraude
mais cette accusation est étayée par
aucun élément probant
d'ailleurs les observateurs
internationaux dont ceux de l'oat
l'organisation des états américains
n'ont relevé aucune irrégularité majeure
alors pour et deuxièmement keiko a une
peur panique celle de se retrouver en
prison
récemment le parquet a requis contre
elle les condamnations de 30 ans de
prison pour corruption pour rappel elle
est la fille d'alberto fujimori l'ancien
président du pays qui est actuellement
emprisonné après avoir été condamné pour
corruption et crime contre l'humanité
pour des tueries perpétrées sous
prétexte de lutte contre la guérilla
d'ailleurs qui est cause la city a
promis que lui accorderait la grâce et
elle est élue alors à quoi faut-il
s'attendre dans les prochains jours
aucune date n'a été fixée pour l'annoncé
des résultats et les partisans des deux
camps manifester chaque jour dans les
rues la situation est très paulin
et a fait en vue des gens s'impatientent
et vu que le score final risque d'être
très très serré quel que soit le
vainqueur proclamé
eh bien il faudra s'attendre à ce que
les partisans du camp d'en face du camp
opposé
protess fortement merci beaucoup meriem
l'arrivée pour ses explications sur le
terreau ou un article à retrouver bien
sûr votre article complet est à
retrouver sur le site d'arte et france
point tv